We're on problem nine.
Use the problem below
to answer the
question that follows.
Given that 100 milliliters is
equal to approximately 0.4
cups, 205 milliliters
is equal to
approximately how many cups?
So we could set up a
little ratio here.
We could say 100 milliliters
is to 0.4 cups as 200
milliliters-- I'll write
the cups here--
is to how many cups?
Just like that.
And so we just have
to solve for x.
To solve for x, we could
essentially cross multiply,
which essentially you're just
multiplying both sides of the
equation by both denominators.
So we get 100x.
100 times x is equal
to 200 times 0.4.
It's not 200, it's 205 to be
exact, 205 times 0.4-- is
equal to 205 times 0.4.
And then we want to divide
both sides by 100.
So x is equal to 205/100
times 0.4.
Let me write it a little
bit different,
0.4, just like that.
We could divide either by 100,
but let's see if any of the
choices look like what we have
there, something times 0.4.
Well this one has subtraction
in it, so
that's not our answer.
This one, also has
subtraction, is not our answer.
105% of 0.4-- that's the same
thing as 1.05 times 0.4.
205% times 0.4-- that's the same
thing is 2.05 times 0.4,
which is exactly what
we have here.
And just to verify, 205 divided
by 100-- I'll do it
right here-- 100
goes into 205.
100 goes into 200 2 times.
2 times 100 is 200.
Let me put a little decimal
right there.
You do the subtraction,
you get 5.
Bring down a 0.
100 goes into 50 0 times.
0 times 100 is 0.
Do the subtraction.
Bring down another 0.
100 goes into 500 5 times.
5 times 100 is 500.
It all evens out to 0.
So you get 2.05.
So this thing is the same thing
as 2.05 times 0.4, which
is the same thing
as 205% of 0.4.
Choice D.
Next problem.
All right, we are
on problem 10.
I'll switch colors.
Use the number line below
to answer the
question that follows.
OK, we have the number line.
What number is represented
by point P on
the number line above?
OK, so they give us two
endpoints, 0.003 and 0.004.
And how many buckets do
we have between them?
We're going one increment.
Oh sorry, I'm on the
wrong layer.
We go one increment, two
increments, three increments,
four increments, five
increments, six increments,
seven increments, eight
increments.
So over eight increments, we
go a distance of how far?
Well, the distance we go is
0.004 minus 0.003, which is
just 0.001.
So this whole distance,
this whole distance
right there, is 0.001.
And so each of these
are 1/8 of 0.001.
Right?
Let me do that in
another color.
All right, we have one,
two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Don't want to make
it any dirtier.
Each of those are
1/8 of 0.001.
Or you could say it's 8 divided
by or 0.001 divided by
8 is how much each of these
increments are.
And what we're at, the point
in question, is exactly two
increments past 0.003.
So let's figure out how
far each increment is.
It's 0.001, which is its entire
distance, divided by 8.
And the best way we can do this,
we'll just put a decimal
right there.
8 goes into 0, 0 times.
8 goes into-- 0 times 8
is 0, bring down a 0.
8 goes into 0 0 times.
Bring down a 0, 0 there.
Bring down a 1.
8 goes into 1 0 times.
0 times 8 is 0.
Bring down the 1.
You could bring down another
0, and now it gets
interesting.
8 goes into 10 1 time.
1 times 8 is 8.
10 minus 8 is 2.
Bring down a 0.
8 goes into 20 2 times.
2 times 8 is 16.
20 minus 16 is 4.
Bring another 0.
8 goes into 40 5 times.
So it's 0.000125.
And you might already know that
1/8 is equal to 0.125.
That's something you might
just know from heart.
And so, if you have this divided
by-- this isn't--
we're not dealing with 1/8,
we're dealing with 0.0018, so
with this divided by 1,000,
you're going to have three 0's
and then your 125.
So that's how much each
increment is.
And we're going two of these
increments, just like that.
So if you multiply this times
2, what do you get?
You say 2 times 125 is 250, but
we have one, two, three,
four, five, six numbers behind
the decimal point.
So one, two, three,
four, five, six.
We have to have six numbers
behind the decimal point in
our answer.
So that's how much we
move above 0.003.
So essentially, this is going to
be 0.000125, another 00125,
and it's all above 0.003.
So our answer is going to be
0.003 plus this-- plus 0.003,
which gets us to 0.00325.
So that is 0.00325.
And I just realized, there is
an actual much, much easier
way to think about it.
Instead of dividing by 8 and all
of that, I could have just
said, you know what?
There are eight increments
here.
I've made this problem messy,
but there are eight increments
here-- one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
We've gone two of them.
So we've gone 1/4
of the distance
between 0.003 and 0.004.
And that would have been the
easiest way to do the problem.
1/4 of the distance is
just another 0.25.
That would've been way easier to
do the problem, especially
if you didn't want to
waste a lot of time.
Problem 11.
A book distributor is trying
to divide an order of
textbooks into equally-sized
groups
for shipping in cartons.
The textbooks can be divided
into groups of 12, groups of
15, or groups of 18, with
no books left over.
So that means that the number of
books we have is divisible
by these three numbers.
Which of the following
inequalities is satisfied if N
is the smallest possible total
number of textbooks?
So essentially, we know that N
is divisible by these three
numbers, and we want to find
the least possible N that's
divisible by these
three numbers.
Or essentially, the least common
multiple of-- so we
want to-- let me write
this down.
N is equal to the least common
multiple of 12, 15, and 18.
And the easiest way for, at
least for me to think about
this type of a least common
multiple problem, is to just
take the factors of each
of these numbers.
Let's take the prime
factorization of these guys,
right here.
So 12, if we want to take the
prime factorization of 12,
it's-- let's see.
We could do a little tree here,
but it's pretty easy.
It's 4 times 3, 4 is the same
thing is 2 times 2 times 3.
That's 12.
So if we just have the least
common multiple of just 12, we
would say, well they have
to have a 2 in it
times a 2 times a 3.
So we have other numbers here.
We have the 15.
Another color.
15 is equal to what?
It's prime factorization
is 3 times 5.
So our answer right now, we
already have a 3 as a prime,
so to make this divisible by
15, we just have to include
the 5 only.
So 3 times 5.
So this number, right now,
is now divisible
by both 12 and 15.
How do I know?
Because all of 12's constituent
factors, or prime
factors, are in this number.
And all of 15's constituent
numbers are in this number.
So this, right now, is
the least common
multiple of 12 and 15.
And then we can throw
18 into the mix.
So 18, that's the same thing
as 2 times 9, or 2
times 3 times 3.
And our answer, here, we already
have a 2 times 3, so
we already have these two
constituents, but we
need another 3.
So let's multiply
by another 3.
Now this is going to be the
least common multiple of 12,
15, and 18, because it has all
of the constituents of all of
these guys.
You have one 2, and two 3's.
A 3 and a 5.
Two 2's and a 3.
You have all the prime factors
of all of these guys, and now
you can just multiply.
4 times 4-- sorry-- 2 times
2 is 4 times 3.
Let me do it-- times
3 times 5 times 3.
4 times 3 is 12 times
5 times 3.
12 times 5 is 60 times 3,
which is equal to 180.
So that is the smallest total
number of books, the least
common multiple of these.
And that means that's
choice B.
180 is between 150 and 200.